d'Ontariens traversent
cette frontière pour établir
leur résidence permanente
au Qué
certains continuent
d'immatriculer leur voitee
en Ontario et même d'y payer
leurs impôts.ieieieieieieieieie"
comme tout le monde fait
pour leurs taxes.
- De nombreux contribuables
Outaouais, en ont assez de faire
les frai c c ce stratagème.
- On a moins de revenus au
Québec. L'impact, c'est t t t ts
pour la santé, pour l'éducation,
pour l'environnement.
Moins chères, les propriétés.
- Bien que la pratique soit
interdite, l'utilisation a a a s
impôts à l'extérieur du Québec
peut s'avérer très payante.
ÉRIC GÉLINAS, prof, École
- À tous les niveaux, c'estpluse
en Ontario, puis de façon assez
substantie
Quand on fait la comparaison
par tranche de revenus, bien
c'est sûr qu'il y a
une différence, c'est
- Un contribuable qui gagne
50 000 $ par année poioioioioioo
qu'au Québec. Avec un revenu
de 100 000 $, c'est 5000 $
de moins et ainsi de suite.
au fait du stratagème
de fausses adresses qui a cours
dans des régions frontalières
comme Ottawa-Gatineau.DeDeDeDep,
une équipe spécialisée dans
le domaine
fiscale a épluché les dossiers
de près de 500 contribuabl
et a envoyé des factures
totalisant 7 millions...........
Même la Sûreté du Québec
s'est mise de la partie.
Durant la pandémie,
des résidents du Québec qui
avaient encore une adresse
officielle en Ontario. Ils ont
de citoyens qui soupçonnent
leurs voisins de fraude fiscale.
En tout, une cinquantaine
de dos
à Revenu Québec.
ANDRÉ FORTIN
député, PLQ, Pontiac
- La Sûreté du Québec nousêêêêêt
sur plusieurs personnes.
Je sais qu'il y a plusieurs
enquêtes qui sont ouvertes
qui ont dû payer des amendes,
des gens qûûûûû transférer
leurs papiers.
- La crainte, c'est queécécécécu
cours des dernières années
ne représentent qu'une infime
partie des pertes fiscales
- Il y a des gens qui sont bien,
15 ans, 20 ans et qui savent
que le régleur est plus avantag.
Donc, ils trouvent une façon
de contourner le système,
mais c'est de la fraude.
ont récupéré, mais ce qu'on nein
on perd collectivement.
- D'autres élus dénoncen
MATHIEU LACOMBE, ministre de la
région de l'Outaouais, Québec
- C'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
avoir le meilleur OuOuOuOuOuOuO,
ça agace les gens. Donc, je suis
bien content que Revenu Québec,
la Sûreté du Québec aussi,
on lisairararararararararararar.
- J'invite les gens, bien sûr
de l'Ontario, qui papapapapapapt
des impôts qui sont payés
par l'ensemble de la communauté
à faire ce qu'ils doivent faire
pour eux aèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèè.
- Ce débat risque de prendre
de l'ampleur alo